perdre et qui c'est qui est en train de
bosser c'est sébastien s'est mis à
tourner un homme a cessé en espagne la
cepal italiano mehmedi ce monde malade
jean pas mal pas mal
[Musique]
regardez qui j'ai ramené c'est la france
et la suisse et ross monsieur franco
suisse en cause six
on est devant le palais palais ou
congras catalunya là ça se voit à peu
près ici on à la conférence de shiao me
présentation du mil neuf
[Musique]
la suisse travaille
jacqueline et de regarder rien n'a
vraiment pas ni les mêmes budgets même
calibre personnes vont avec quoi je en
train de filmer donc le monde à côté
mais bon ça c'est plus grands comptes
kato à quoi bon alors à ton avis nous
faisons quoi aujourd'hui
à ce jour seuls chez michelin il nous
présente pas aujourd'hui
le futur est en marche le futur
attendant j'espère que le culture
d'arrivée ouais normalement il va
arriver futur et ensuite et regarde on
est filmé
et normal l'international allemand
devrait avoir aussi
notre centre est a priori
et c'est quoi la sur le futur est en
marche ah bon merci adrien tu nous as
trouve un plan d'enfer grâce à toi on
peut reprendre des forces
il n'y a pas du père il ya pas essayé il
ya des périodes là ya du période c'est
le placement de produits non ceci n'est
pas un placement de produit
mais c'est vrai qu'on pourrait le croire
on pourrait pas changer tournoi au
nouristan coca cola serait vachement
plus vendeur en fait mais ce que je sais
rien sur derrière la condition me vient
d'avoir lieu
grosse nouveauté sur le 1900 on l'a déjà
vu il ya déjà eu pas mal d'infos dessus
on n'a pas appris des trucs folk on ne
savait pas déjà eu quelques nouveautés
en termes de lumière connecter chez omis
avance notamment avec un mix 3 vraiment
un focus sur la 5g un nouveau modèle
spécial 5 g ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on sort de la la il ya beaucoup de
lumière beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
bruit entre l'extérieur et on n'a pas
d'ensemble
bah écoute
très très sympathique et en plus de
voilà ça c'est quand même
avec toutes les caractéristiques le
c'est
dans la conférence c'est 100 web
en fait là où on part dans le métro
quand il en fait schumi
c'est la quatrième marque aux mots avec
deux milieux catalogue on s'en rend pas
forcément compte mais l'écosystème et
beaucoup de monde au repos ça bouge
l'écosystème est complètement
hallucinant lors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ils ont effectivement fait un
tour de france avec la 5g
ils sortent le mx3 en 5 j il adore avec
eux ça toi ouais mais pas le vinaigre et
mais pas le minfi revenons pas parler
dit elle on parlait du mx 3 en 5 j
cardiol du coup l'intérêt de la 5g c'est
quoi effectivement d'avoir des
connexions plus rapides pas de latence
de télécharger très rapidement ça va
être idéal pour regarder une vidéo pour
le cloud gainey va vraiment se
développer en 2010 9,7 un truc
complètement essentiel d'avoir cette
solution là sur des smartphones
notamment chez un liverpool
l'électron avec son très grand écran ça
très clairement 123 qui fait cette fois
ci du teint doré gold 855 quelques
équipes et du sein dragonne x50 qui est
le modèle à 5 g qu'on trouve directement
dans ce smartphone qui lui permet d'être
compatible alors nous on fait une démo
d'un appel à 5 g oui ça orange donc on
va que la saint jean en marche froid
énormément en parler dans le cas du mwc
pense que j'ai la chance de partir avec
qualcomm et qui justement bosse sur l'a5
j'ai donc on a plein de choses hyper
intéressante à voir pour mettre en
valeur et de spots parce qu'ici ça c'est
très bon mix 3 5 juin qui sera dispo
2009 tarif de 199 euros et uniquement
sur le réseau orange pour l'instant
goody en france la salle g on n'est pas
encore donc il va falloir s'armer de
patience avant que il ya un intérêt réel
cachet ce smartphone en tout cas dans
l'hexagone en suisse jette comment
niveau de la 5 0 5 g & byers avait
annoncé sunrise et puis je sais que
suisse comme easy sont donc ça va
ça va barder ça va le faire grâce à le
faire heureusement qu'on a un
spécialiste du pays avec nous exactement
sacrements comme qui dirait
un suisse - suisse cois parce que
qu'est-ce qui fait la nuit j'ai pas je
suis apparu comme ça par majid perdu
pour passer sa sentence mois 2009 rondon
1009 pas mal franchement pour le prix au
niveau du rapport qualité prix vraiment
pas mal c'est plutôt naïve pour le prix
après avoir avalé en main à voir en
terme de performance il ya du snap
dragon 855 n'y aura pas de souci à ce
niveau-là mais pas trop fan mais voilà
des grands en fait brandon
mais toi aussi t'es pas mal mesure
combien ce que la centrale alors on va
dire un mètre 83 84 mais je me fais
vieux donc non c'est moi qui faisais
rien j'adore la place d'espagne
tu connais pas d'espagne à tout jamais
welcome jamais ouais c'est vachement
bien ici parlons justement 2009
on se pose la place d'espagne dans
quelques instants on va commencer la
conférence de huawei alors on enchaîne
xiaoming matin huawei l'après midi c'est
le mwc ça n'arrête pas alors on va
parler un petit peu du design ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez un
smartphone qui pousse enfin que ce que
vous aviez sur le mid 8 avec des bords
incurvés gelé pris en main rapidement
serait que la prise en main c'est bien
il faudra voir effectivement lors des
phases de test est ce que ça va donner
parce que comme ça en prise en main
rapide dans un salon il ya beaucoup de
monde sur très compliqué se rendre
compte néanmoins c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt sympa qu'il ait pas lourd il pèse
173 g et l'épaisseur je crois que c'est
7 61 mm dans vous dire franchement c'est
un truc qui est pas très épais en plus
ce qui est sympa c'est que vous avez un
effet holographique sur smartphone alors
ils appellent ça commençait le nano
lieven holographique les faits plutôt
bien vous avez trois couleurs
principales 1 lavande un peu rose avec
des effets bleuté un peu vers un bleu
bleu océan et une couleur noire
personnellement je préfère quand même la
bleue la rose beaucoup plus punchy
beaucoup plus sympa enfin corning
gorilla glass 6 pour venir protéger
votre smartphone et en plus petit point
de détail au niveau de la caméra
principale vous avez un petit halo de
couleurs ce qui fait que ça va un petit
peu le faire ressortir et ça renforce au
design et vous avez si l'appel de saphir
glace qui veulent protéger votre caméra
arrière lorsque vous posez votre
smartphone sur une taxe quoi que ce soit
ça
le protéger contre les rayons entre les
coûts donc ça aussi c'est vraiment
intéressant on a un écran enfant tu
goûtes d'eau une petite encoche en forme
de goutte d'eau un écran amoled de 6,39
pouces avec un ratio de 19 points 5/9
une fois de plus un truc qui va falloir
prendre en main pour se rendre compte
mais bon on connaît le savoir-faire de
chirurgie là dessus je m'inquiète
absolument pas en termes de savoir-faire
qualité en termes de performances ont
mis le paquet avec le dernier soc de
qualcomm le stand dragonne 855
vous savez le crio 485 dépôts coté
graphics tout l'adreno 640 mon sens
s'inquiète pas ça va tartiner ça va
rouler vous avez s'ils gagnent rarement
par smartphone qui devrait être fluide
avoir de bonnes performances je pense
notamment en termes de gaming et nous
balance un score sur un tout où je n'ai
pas appris par coeur de 387 1851
ce qui serait juste énorme massif ça une
fois de plus à bord il a confirmé lors
des phases de test vous savez un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée sous
l'écran alors c'est bien que c'est
surprenant qu'on n'est pas un capteur à
ultrasons comment on peut retrouver sur
les galaxy s 10 et se disent plus vu que
le snapdragon 1 855 le supporte bon
peut-être pour des questions de coûts
allez savoir
en termes d'autonomie on devrait pas mal
avec une patrie de 3300 millions paire
eur alors même si sur le papier ça
paraît pas énorme il faut vraiment
savoir que vous avez une optimisation
déjà avec le ca dragon 855 vraiment
venir optimiser la gestion de votre
batterie donc vraiment l'utiliser quand
vous en avez besoin et quand vous avez
pas besoin notamment sur les applis en
tâche de fond ça soit tranquille ça rit
pas consommer
ça c'est bien derrière de l'autre une
partie software développé par shiomi
avec de l'intelligence artificielle
devenir complètement aussi finir
d'optimiser la bécane s'associent en
coiffant et point très intéressant vous
avez de la recharge sans fil
oui mais la recharge sans fil rapide 20
watts permettra d'aller beaucoup plus
vite
plus qu'intéressante c'est forcément
compatibles savard charge et plein
d'autres smartphones pour s'associer un
très bon point de la partie soit médias
voilà il ya beaucoup de smartphones qui
ont de la recharge sans fil nous à la
recharge sans fil rapide
on est en avance plutôt cool en gros
vous rechargez votre smartphone à santon
190 me côté photo maintenant alors je
n'ai pas appris par coeur donc je
regarde un peu les antisèches vous avez
un téléobjectif x 2 capteur 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
capteurs samsun ça vous intéresse vous
avez aussi à la caméra sony mx 5 186 le
premier modèle équipé c'était le honor
view 20 c'est une caméra 48 mégapixels
qui permet vraiment d'aller chercher des
points de détails dans l'image d'aller
pouvoir zoomer et surtout pour les
photos de nuit vous avez la techno 4
pixels en un an vous prenez 4 pixels
ça vous sort une image en fauteuil nuit
un équivalent 12 mégapixels
franchement c'est très bien ça marche
bien je dirais tester si assez
intéressant de toute façon on sait très
bien que si on m'y a vraiment des
caméras ayant trait au logiciel de
qualité qui ont déjà prouvé par le passé
avec d'autres smartphones 2008 était bon
je pense que la lumineuse franchement on
va faire hyper mal et itamar et
concurrence et on a une ouverture de f
1.75 et on trouve aussi un ultra
grand-angle caméra de 5 mégapixels et
une caméra sony avec une ouverture de f
2.2 et un angle de 117 degré simplement
plus grand temps qu'on a sur le samsung
galaxy s dise où on a un an vous 123°
bon 123° 117 une grève ou gears est allé
voir la différence et vous pouvez filmer
en 960 images par seconde en slow motion
alors je sais pas je pense que c'est du
1080p on confirmera également lors des
phases de tests et à l'avant vous avez
une caméra cette fille de faim
mégapixels avec de l'intelligence
artificielle sur notre portrait plutôt
cool bien évidemment une recharge en usb
type c est un smartphone qu'on va
trouver en tarif
aussi j gap le 64 giga à 449 euros c'est
juste officines c'est hyper agressif au
prix et si j'y viendrai plus 128 go de
stockage 499 euros c'est-à-dire moins
500 euros et si vous regardez ce titre à
la concurrence la chaume istres vraiment
fort et agressif en disant ok il ya
beaucoup d'offres hockey et beaucoup de
smartphones nous déjà on a dernier soc
de qualcomm on a un truc hyper hyper
vite on a beaucoup de puissance
on est à recharge sans fil rapide et en
plus on est à moins de 500 euros et ça
croyez moi c'est affaire hyper mal
perdre et qui c'est qui est en train de
bosser fait sébastien s'est mis à danser
à l'homme a cessé en espagne la cepal
italien mais disent non à tout va mal
pas mal
un smartphone qui est disponible dès
aujourd'hui en pré commande d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse vous aimez les liens
en bas dans la description
alors il ya eu d'autres produits de
présenter il ya eu un miled à smart
bates et un éclairage intérieur
d'ambiance tarifs hyper agressif à 19
euros 90 ya aussi le en plus collectif
avec pas mal qui truquent en gros ce
convoi jusqu'à super intéressant c'est
que shiomi on reste toujours plus sur la
5 gt la première conférence disait dans
le cadre du mwc dont franchement ils
vont plus loin ils vont plus vite ils
ont des connections hyper rapides ils
sont toujours beaucoup plus agressive
avec deux top performances avec des
photos d'eux ouvre un smartphone qui
promet d'être juste dingue issime on
testera on en reparlera vous et moi ce
que vous en pensez est ce que vous
trouvez que xiaomi continue à mettre la
barre hyper ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils vont tous défoncés en termes de
prix vous marquez tout ça on en reparle
très bientôt et restez connectés parce
que là on est à barcelone et au mwc
il ya plein d'actus ya plein de
smartphones ya plein de choses on parle
5 j invite à faire une chambre enfin
deux choses la première c'est à vous a
donné fatalement et la deuxième se
regarder ma playlist avoir toutes les
infos sur la queue du moment vous
embrasse pour les soignants
m